home security cameras they can be great
for monitoring deliveries
keeping an eye on your house and of
course spying on your cats in fact
around 14 of us households with
broadband now use an internet connected
camera and the us market for home
security cameras is projected to
continue growing rapidly through 2030
but their popularity has come at a cost
amazon's ring doorbell may not be as
private as you think hackers tapping
into those home cameras i'll leave you
and your family alone or i could do this
just this year amazon owned ring handed
over surveillance footage to law
enforcement 11 times without a warrant
or customer consent the company said the
request met its exception for
emergencies which it defines as danger
of death or serious physical injury and
since cats have nine lives and always
land on their feet i figured caneco a
manhattan-based cat cafe wouldn't be at
any risk of law enforcement stepping in
but there's a stereotype with cats and
it's that they're burglars and we'd like
to prove otherwise with this video
so that's why it's a perfect place to
come and outline some do's and don'ts
for you to consider when setting up and
installing some of the latest smart
surveillance cameras
of course joe golka caneco's cattery
guide was with us all day to ensure that
these rescued and adoptable cats were
happy and comfortable right you know you
can hang with me and that no real paws
were used
if you want your valuable recordings
shielded from prying eyes you should try
to enable end-to-end encryption
but what does that mean and what does it
do
to keep it simple let's say cameras
typically use one of two encryption
types there's standard encryption and
then there's end-to-end encryption
imagine two companies cat cam and dog
cam cat cam has end to end encryption
which means the only user with the key
to decrypt your video files is you well
you and anyone you share the account
with so end to end encryption protects
your data from hackers and prevents it
from being viewed by others such as law
enforcement or cat cam dog cam encrypts
your video when it's traveling from you
to company servers but it doesn't do it
end to end which means the company can
also hold the key to decrypt your
recordings if you're looking for
end-to-end encryption nicole recommends
a camera that works with apple's smart
home platform called homekit i like
these devices because end-to-end
encryption is on by default logitech's
circle view camera or doorbell are good
picks
they work indoor or outdoor and have
face recognition to identify different
people in your household or frequent
visitors
end-to-end encryption isn't limited to
just home kit cameras for instance you
can now enable it on some ring cameras
but it's not on by default and another
important note it's not available for
their battery-powered models and
disables some key features
no matter which brand you choose be sure
to use a secure password
don't point your camera at private
spaces security cameras usually have
ultra wide lenses that capture far more
than say a normal smartphone camera
would so it's important to consider the
expectation of privacy when installing
one ask yourself what would you be
comfortable with if you've got a
doorbell style security camera try not
to capture a shot into your neighbor's
front window and if there's a zone in
your camera's field of view you'd rather
not capture try enabling motion
detection or privacy zones cameras from
these brands all feature activity zone
triggering any home kit camera such as
those from eve or logitech ring google
nest and arlo ring devices can also set
up privacy zones which will black out
areas from being recorded in videos
do consider location factors if you're
looking to monitor an entire space
indoors it's best to keep your camera at
a higher location this will give you the
widest field of view then ask yourself
do i need night vision at my camera's
location if so make sure your security
camera has an infrared spotlight which
will enable it to capture video and
images in little to no light
also if your camera is being used as a
baby monitor or in a location where
silence is important it's worth noting
many security cameras can click when
activating their infrared light if
you're in a noise sensitive environment
try disabling night vision and buying a
separate infrared illuminator
and always be sure to let everyone in
your household or location know there's
a camera don't forget about hardware
quirks in the world of security cameras
you have outdoor cameras and indoor
cameras battery powered cameras can live
outside for months without having to be
recharged or having any pesky wires run
to them which makes it easy to forget
when they need to be charged
don't be a jerk or creep many brands let
you clip recordings which can then be
posted to social media
ring even has its own network called
neighbors
this for a place like caneco can be
great when they want to post clips of
their in-house influencers for public
consumption
but security cam users should always
think twice before posting to social
media that's because it's easy for
nefarious internet passers-by to
triangulate your location simply by
landmarks outside also a case of
mistaken identity or misunderstanding
can lead to an accidental tragedy
somebody getting fired all sorts of bad
things so before you post something
online take a breath think twice
and consider the outcome
[Music]